hello welcome to this video playing the
fat cat trying the and why do the hawk
or 93 that's weird wow that looks that
looks strange to be honest maybe if I
for looks like a very logical move and
of course it's answered immediately mmm
some right before I can also go back 37
if five movers are you telling me
mmm I wonder if I can do something
interesting now something like c6 maybe
a SATA move it's kind of interesting and
these 696 loses a pawn and Bishop c4 cd5
should be pretty good can you play it so
quickly it and get it isn't that winning
stuff it is completely unfazed yeah just
like move move move okay so i can take
here sure each fives g4 takes on f3
takes on age 5 is also interesting but
there is no direct way
so work g1 I guess and then what a weird
position the check on a4 is not
particularly dangerous okay I'll go h5
here very weird position yeah my idea
was to activate the night here and
possibly go night f5 that the pawn on d4
was limiting my at five night Queen a 4f
20 27 maybe no don't think so I was just
thinking maybe you can do something
weird like Queen a for check 27 might be
five looks very strange but my Jack
might be might be on I don't have any
alternative anyway might be five hmm
very wacky move but I can't castle right
I can cancel long in this position or do
I have something better let's check TX
bishop TX knight c6 d takes its X is
there something that I can try here okay
let's cancel long
gets it super weird position but damn i
don't really am don't believe believe in
it so much for white thats it's an
interesting move down hmm wow so night a
seven is mate let's um let's indeed
pretty big threat Wow okay
you can take bishop chicks but I can
take on d5 right okay I have to play now
check 96 bishops is yes I'm just hoping
that I have something but maybe well
maybe that is not such a terrible
situation I mean Bishop takes pawn takes
rook TX King b7 is set a checkmate am I
getting checkmated don't see it at the
moment check show me don't see it just
taking everything and we now think i'm
also threatening stuff on my own them
and in some cases I mean this king is
not not exactly safe and at the moment I
don't even see a meaningful check Luke
p6 I mean I go to a 8 and that's it
manager I'm just winning I think
check okay he has no Queen move that
threatens made on b7 so and I'm
threatening Bishop before check now with
a direct way now think the Queen takes
creamy one mate
love white resigns yeah so love is out
of bullets okay I was tough yeah that is
a good line anyway a five hmm now maybe
I can try to win that point quite
quickly word okay i don't i don't think
this is bad III five now I push this the
engine gives night before and then c6a
there's some logic to it if you're going
to play c6 that makes quite some sense
so we'll see six bishop cheeks and yeah
the engine actually lies and likes white
chair now aged five hats a tough
decision okay the term computer hates it
then it wants to go d6 now chatter for
the chick here yeah they're so that's
quite have quite quite room now well
Matt I was very good for him Janet came
but don't look tempting okay night if
five is also given by the engine with a
win and this is what their computers
first evaluation is equal which is kind
of funny okay here white can win with a
six a six wins
yeah my king position is more than
dangerous I cannot take it and there's
also the threat then of a 7 I mean okay
also threatens to take but a 7 as an
additional issue Wow okay check and
after that after that i'm winning up his
sort of out of ideas mmm yeah that was
very technically technically a sharp
game tough to play okay thanks for
watching